uh and we can have to panel this uh
videos pinned up uh um
but um uh so
so today's panel is uh you know it it
consists of three people who are
who are both closely related to uh
to uh you know to this work from
different directions so
um mother sudan uh
uh is you know was one of the one of the
primary architects of the pcb theorem uh
he's currently at harvard he did his
work on the pcb theorem while he was a
student basically student at berkeley
it's a welcome mother
and then we have two mathematicians uh
we have
uh marius young who is at uh
in the mathematics department at uiuc
um his his work is on uh you know he
works on functional analysis and c star
algebras
and i think he was involved in in there
in the
in the proof uh showing the equivalence
conjecture and khan's and letting
uh conjecture um and then uh william
soft
slaustra who is uh at the at the
university of
um of waterloo
he he works on the mathematics of
of quantum information and quantum
computation
and he's extensively studied questions
about
the value of entangles entangled games
and silences conjecture so
so welcome everybody and uh maybe uh
maybe we can start with uh with a few uh
you know just a three four minute
uh minute comment by each of you about
uh henry's talk and also about these
you know as henry said there are many
many different directions from which to
look at this result so
you know please do look at it from you
know the directions that you would like
to
and so
maybe mother um sure i don't know if i
have three to four minutes worth it
could be
an hour or it could be a minute uh we'll
see how this goes uh so first i mean i
want to echo what scott's
uh said in the uh in the chat already
it's a really beautiful talk and thanks
very much for giving us intuition into
why we're getting this squeezing
happening
um a few quantitative
questions about the talk so maybe that's
the way i want to think of it
um was you talked a lot about the
verifier's complexity
did we speak at all about the
communication
how much communication was there between
the verifier and the
uh provers so maybe a
batch pro you can bash process the
answers so i'll ask a few questions that
i have
different directions and you can give me
a sense about
the answers later when you get a chance
um a second thing was
we talked a lot about this lower degree
testing
in the world of computer science there's
a much simpler
test the linearity test it's sort of
more basic
has the same quantitative effect that
you ask very few questions
and verify properties about some growing
object
would that have been good enough for you
to do your
[Music]
entanglement testing or did you really
need this
degree test was there something
quantitative about
the difference in these parameters which
makes one work the other doesn't work
in general if you had to choose the two
parameters how many variables do i have
and how much degree of a polynomial do i
want to work with
is there some trade-off between the two
that uh that makes things work
uh finally i mean well this magic square
property
it's really very intriguing to me that
you're sort of putting a magic square
property
on top of a low degree test whereas i
think of the low degree test as sitting
on top of a magic square property which
is a very different
magic square but somehow the very idea
that you know you sort of ask questions
along one line
a different line and then you look at
this
two-dimensional plane spanned by these
two lines
and see that there is some sort of a
consistency that you're asking for the
lines in one direction
should all form polynomials and that
implies that the lines in another
direction will form for allowance
so there's a i don't know if there is
this magic square uh properties inherent
to
your i mean if you could you have worked
with any locally testable code or did
you really need
a locally testable code which was
analyzed using this
uh property okay so that's probably the
kinds of things that i
had in mind um i'll let you measure okay
it's very it's very appropriate mother
that
in keeping with the with with
interactive proofs you chose to
make your role on panelists as being
interactive with henry so
henry do you want to respond to
all these comments they have really good
questions yeah
i can try to respond also i i noticed
that um you know tomo and
john and maybe anand are on so please
feel free to
uh jump in um
so yeah so um your first question was
complexity versus time complexity versus
communication complexity
um the communication here we we allowed
to be as
up to the time complexity so if that it
was poly log t
is the time complexity then that's the
amount of communication that we allow to
go back and forth
um
um let's see uh
and then you're asking me what about a
simpler test like the linearity test
and um uh i think
actually to get the so there is an
entanglement test based on the linearity
test that the
unended uh and uh tomah developed this
earlier called the poly braiding test
and it's very robust
but in order to certify let's say n
qubits of entanglement then the
communication complexity has to be
n so there's no
[Music]
savings so somehow
it seems like going so increasing
allowing you know the higher degree is
is
uh useful you're asking um
what degree is needed and actually that
constant degree is fine
so like three i think is fine
uh so it doesn't need to be very very
high degree but three is enough to to
get some saving well i mean
actually you know to to go from uh
uh you know polynomial to poly
logarithmic is overkill in the sense
because once you can just get a little
bit of savings you can just
recurse and you know as many times as
you would like
um yeah and then you had a question
about
the magic square game versus the low
degree test
actually i don't know maybe john do you
have any
uh i know you've thought about this
i don't know john are you listening
uh i'm listening but i don't really have
a great answer
as far as i can tell uh they just both
happen to
involve squares but two different
squares
i did spend quite some time actually
trying to see if you could compose them
in some way that created a more
beautiful object that wasn't just these
two separate tests and
i never really got anywhere but i think
it remains an interesting open question
i don't know anan just appeared so maybe
he wants to step in and answer this as
well
oh yeah i guess the one connection is um
we were thinking about like you know
ultimately we have to use the axis
parallel low degree test
um and then we had to add this sort of
annoying
um subtest uniquely for the quantum case
where you uh pick like not an axis
parallel line but like a diagonal line
and you check for commutativity of
measurements along the diagonal line
and then you might ask like is this test
strictly necessary
and um that's a case where you know the
the two notions of square
actually match up so you can say yes
it's necessary because otherwise you
could do something
magic squarey or like the axis parallel
lines commute but the diagonal lines
don't commute
um yeah okay uh alan while i have you
can you just comment then if
the access parallel line was important
how is it that the linearity test
manages to work oh
um i mean the linearity test is like
testing
all possible lines right so you're
you know in particular you're certifying
that all pairs of observables
commute right because you can fit a line
through any pair of observables
i mean um strictly speaking i think the
standard low degree test also works
but the way we analyzed it was using the
analysis of the uh access parallel
alliance test
so since it was easier to analyze it
that way we just phrased it in terms of
that test
i think you could also just get it for
the standard low degree test you would
just not get the standard low degree
test summaries
you get the weaker access parallel
alliance tests on this
thanks
great um so
marius would you like to oh yeah
absolutely so
so um first of all i really have to
thank this crowd for solving this
problem i mean you you
have no idea what that means to us right
i mean i'm coming from operate
algebras i have talked to experts in
this field
and they told me in the morning they
believed con embedding is true
and the afternoon they thought it's
false but some days it was the other way
around
and i cannot give you the name of the
person i talked to it would you know
breach of confidentiality but that was
the state of the art
for william and you guys entered the
scene
so um the point is that
the the conjecture was not even
formulated a conjecture it was kind of a
sight remark we don't know and then
one of these problems where simply we
had no idea what's going on
and of course your proof is in some
sense a blessing and a nightmare
the blessing because the answers um the
question is answered and we now know why
it was so hard to
to you know deal with this for such a
long time and it's a nightmare because
our techniques simply don't shed any
light on
you know why why this is true or not i
mean i think that's a
big open gap still to be filled right
um so often people associate con
embedding problem with this problem
the name which should come up just as a
matter of fairness is keirsburg
he made the transition from this hyper
finite
for neumann algebra language to the
group c star algebra language
and the group c styles while language
goes gives them
the transition to these finite state
configurations and that is the
connection to the
i mean there's a direct connection to
these parameters encoded in
in two player games right so so so that
is the
the history and um in fact you know the
discovery was exactly like this
um werner schultz gave a talk on the
certain problem
in in a quantum conference which i
happened to visit because i was
interested and
after the talk i said that's quite
embedding so it is really you know
if you know the parameters that's not
it's pretty easy to see but it really
follows from kirshberg's work so
so these are the things i have to say
and it appears that
this recursive idea which you use right
i mean to go from one set of games to
another set of games
that is i don't know for me that is a
real mystery right so that
that this is effective in this this
background of course
i know that there's you know pcp
tradition there's a lot of tradition on
the computer side
side but that is still completely
mysterious
that i mean i i see the power but i mean
i don't understand it in my bones why
this really
makes a big difference right so this is
unbelievable
it's from it would be would be out of
sight
from our perspective yeah and then i
want to thank you you essentially
answered my
intermediate question with the picture
right i mean you you have these you
guarantee a lot of entanglement
but you only test it in a few
coordinates and that means you can use
the rest of the entanglement to do
whatever
and that answered my question which i
had in the beginning which makes it a
little paradox right
i think this also answers some of the
questions of
you know whether randomness is preserved
or entanglement is preserved
i think you have to just preserve both
right in the
in your inductive procedure you have to
adjust if i understand it correctly
right you have to
preserve both parameters in a reasonable
way
yeah this were my comments um the only
question in terms of you know
verification is
um it would be nice if um
there were a joint effort of
transforming your proof simply in the
language of operators and i think you
can appreciate
because you went the other way around i
mean trying to read our papers and
translate it into complexity questions
so i i think if there is some effort
underway
um either him you don't have to answer
publicly but it would just be very very
nice if somebody
is on that and would could write a paper
which is just
accessible to both communities i think
that would be a great service
you know now we're we are probably
certain that it's true
right no i'm sure you're right but
i mean people have this trust issue
because they cannot understand the other
way of reasoning because they have not
inhaled this for 20 years
right so it's understandable
and i think you can relate because when
you first saw the sister proofs you
probably had the same feeling what on
earth are these people doing right
probably an experience we can all share
thanks uh thanks maria so actually uh
just just a very brief follow-up
question so given
you know uh so given the success of
these methods at this particular problem
are there are the
others uh the you know are there other
uh
um uh questions in the neighborhood that
you could
you you know yeah sure and um in
geometrical theory
like the um this problem about suffix
groups
right or uh uh william you probably know
this better right so
um so the question is very
i mean hypo linear groups every group is
hyperlinear what's the question so
so we are asking for you know we they
solve the problem
for certain cst algebras don't certain
objects in our class don't have that
property
but it would be nice if not it's not
solved for
their existing object which has that
property but
there exists a specific object of
associated to a group
which fails that property so so i think
we have some experts here
the first step in doing this it would be
to verify that all the games you use
are synchronous um
that would go in the right direction and
i i i heard rumors that you guys know
that it's just that i don't know it
right so so so so that would be a first
step so if all the games which are
occur here synchronous that would after
the work of paulson at least
indicate that maybe this is really a
group solution
and then this would solve other i mean
other
problems related to moto geometric group
theory
or this intersection of geometric group
theory and operator algebras
that's one i think william probably
knows more about this than i do but
um and
yeah the other open problems
well there's this big open problem about
group isomorphism right whether
two three groups have the same for
normal algebra if that could also be
handled with this problem this would be
it would be of course a nightmare for
operators but of course fantastic
right so there are problems which if you
can
transform this into a purely group
theoretical result
they they would be not in the vicinity
but you know at least in a large
neighborhood
yeah so so there's hope that this line
of research can
provide more theory and there's also the
group in continuous logic which
already has a lot of reformulations of
of your results right so so so this
there are some community who already
experts on this already
thank you uh william
yeah so um i i want to say as well i i
really enjoyed the
talk uh you gave henry so um
you know non-local games for the past
couple years so i i had kind of had a
front row seat to seeing uh mipstar
equals rea being improved by
uh henry tamah john anand and genfeng
which was a real pleasure my own
interest in it came out of
wanting to know the seroson problems
what the answers to those were
in mainly because i mean it's a really
big important question
uh scientifically but i read uh
cirrhosis papers original papers
when i was a grad student and i just
loved them and um
and then of course there was this
mistake in them that was found by um
uh i guess um first uh miguel navasquez
uh peroneo and and uh athene
and um and then uh led
i guess into the paper that marius wrote
about his connection with his connection
with con embedding
um and uh and i just kind of wanted to
know what the answer was to this uh
these uh this this conflict with this
this paper
and the work that he'd started so it's
really nice to to resolve that
and i guess the question then which
maybe when we have a panel with uh
kind of multi-disciplinary experts
together is kind of interesting to talk
about is where do we go from
from here um and from my point of view i
i've been getting more and more
interested in
kind of the algebraic side that maurice
is talking about the connection with con
embedding and so on
and uh and especially the
the part of what you might call
approximate representation theory
which is i think really maps exactly
onto what henry's talking about about
non-commutative property testing
so i'm glad um that has come up
um the uh
the questions there are essentially when
you start thinking about algebra so you
have generators and relations and you
want to
understand um their uh representations
in matrices or maybe in operators on the
hilbert space
but then maybe you want to be a little
less strict about it as
often happens in something like quantum
information theory where you have noise
you know just say that the relations
hold but you have uh the relations hold
up to epsilon
that's what you call approximate
representation theory so um
the the con embedding theorem is really
fundamental uh
for that um it says that uh you can have
algebras and i think henry maybe uh you
better
jump in and just double check that i'm
right about that but you can do it with
synchronous algebras in your paper right
there they're synchronous games
so you can write down uh specific yeah
so you can write down specific algebras
where you can't
uh you you can have something in the
algebra which is
is non-zero as an element of the algebra
or actually
even more relevant you can have a
tracial state on it which
shows that thing is non-zero but then
there's no way to actually
approximate that um and see that that is
non-zero
with um with finite dimensional
approximate representations
um so that's the the kind of uh the core
application of this
[Music]
of the mipster equals our e to
approximate representation theory but
then we get a lot of interesting things
that come out of that i don't think the
story is over at all
um maybe the most uh pressing one is as
maria said it's just can we
trans can we find a translation of the
so we know that
a lot of questions about non-local games
translates in into questions about
algebra
algebras and so can we take the mipstar
equals re
um proof and put it in terms of
something that's entirely in terms of
algebras
i think that would be really nice to
help the um
the broader mathematical community
digest
the result and henry i know you've
mentioned working on
stuff like that so that might be kind of
interesting to hear about where the
standing of that is
but the other really interesting aspect
of it is just once we start combining
these two areas
um that it suggests new research
problems in particular uh bringing
ideas of efficiency into approximate
representation theory just thinking
about like um
how do uh stability questions change uh
um or what kind of new stability
questions do we get when we start
thinking about
how we trade off number of relations
versus the stability constant
and um and uh
uh stability constant how close do we
have to actually stability question is
where we say something like
you have an approximate representation
is it close to an actual representation
so the stability constant or constants
would be uh how close do you need to be
and then how far away do you end up
being
uh how close you have to be before the
result kicks in that would be like um
your threshold in the um in a in a pcp
for how
trying to pass the test and then how
close do you end up being that's your
delta in henry's talk to the actual um
uh to the to the exact representation
and then your um
your uh efficiency of the verifier i
guess would be something like
uh the number of relations that you need
to consider in your
um in your algebra um but there's
maybe a couple different things you
could put in there so it's i'm not sure
we know exactly what the most
interesting way to ask the questions are
but
clearly it's really the crucial or one
of the crucial issues that come up in
the mipster equals already proof
and so we should be we should be kind of
studying questions um around that
and then there's also the question of
descriptive complexity which is um
how when we look at a proof of mipstar
equals re how complicated do the proofs
have to be and so can we prove them in
particular with what are called linear
system games
that matches really well onto a question
of can you have a non-hyperlinear group
which we'd like to have on the algebraic
side
which is not to say any old algebra that
has this
finite approximation does not have this
finite approximation property
but um but specifically a group algebra
which does not have this finite
approximation property
um so i think there's just a lot of
interesting
research questions that come out of this
that will be interesting to see what uh
what happens with those
um and i'm kind of curious to hear uh
henry
and other panelists or thoughts on where
they might go
oh i should also say while i have the
mic just that uh marius i think i was a
little too strict on what i said with
property
t so there are with the actual result
it's nice to be able to just google
things while you're out of talk
uh with this online format but that the
actual result is just some of the common
property key groups
if you know that they're hyperlinear and
property t then they can't be stable
so i don't think it's kind of suggestive
that maybe we don't know how to combine
stability with property t
you probably know the same result i'm
sure so then uh but it's not a very
strong obstacle to
uh to trying to find some connection to
property t with a mipster equals re
anyway well i think it's often more the
the spirit right so i mean i think that
in fact one of these very important
concepts used is that
there's some kind of rigidity if you if
you are very close to a certain you know
if you can verify
that a certain configuration uh happens
with large probability then then the
the whole algebraic setup has to be very
close to the group which you had in mind
in the first place or to the algebra
which you had in mind in the first place
so this is a really
saying that finitely many conditions up
to epsilon
guarantee that you have almost an
infinite dimensional
amount of information at your disposal
and and that's i mean your work does
verify that in a certain sense all the
rigidity results
verify that that you know you have a lot
of entanglement so many of these
generators have to commute they have to
look in a certain way
so these are all results in this
direction which are but used as
technical tools if i understand it
correctly
but this phenomena is of course
interesting in other
for other applications
yeah i totally agree it's kind of the
the zoomed out level
of how does um you know how does this
interact with the stuff we already know
in algebra like the property t
uh stuff um
be really interesting to see how it
how it kind of connects great um
thank you william so henry would you
like to
add your comments
um yeah i guess uh
i i don't have so much of a comment but
more questions along
you know because uh you know i i'm not
very familiar with
what's going on in approximate
representation theory but when i hear
about it it sounds
very familiar to to these questions
about like property testing so
i i guess one question i have is
um in approximate representation
representation theory
it's you know you have questions about
robustness like if you have something
that's close to
and a representation can you round it um
but
it doesn't seem like there's um
considerations of efficiency
whereas in the property testing world
efficiency and robustness
like the trade-offs between the two are
very important so so
just as an example like uh i think like
madu brought up
linearity testing so let's say you have
a
a boolean function and you want to test
whether
the function is defined over you know
the hypercube and you want to test
whether the function is
close to a linear function so you can do
this um
you know pretty robustly
but uh trying to develop entanglement
tests based on it doesn't give you
quite enough to to get um
somehow the complexity you're not
getting any savings in complexity but
you're getting robustness
uh whereas with the low degree test
um you're getting something extra uh and
and due to
you know some efficiency gains so
so i guess my question is like in in you
say approximate representation theory or
operator algebras
do people are there any questions where
people think about efficiency or
i think that the phenomena i see not
mostly
related to robustness right so i mean
the easiest thing is you have
a certain number of operators they have
an almost fixed point
right can i show that that the whole
group of operators has a fixed point so
this is robustness right i check
there's finally many conditions and then
i can guarantee that you know all of
these guys
need a certain vector almost invariant
right so that that's the that's the
idea of cash down property t this is all
about robustness right and then there's
an epsilon delta relation
now i don't even know where the
complexity
would come into such a question i have
not even seen a formulation
um so so so i think that's something
which was not on our radar
right
um but of course you know if you write
down a proof
for you know if this happens then that
happens
then of course you can you can maybe add
other aspects or
i think what what happened in your
proofs a lot is you have
you know two pairs of configurations
and you're gonna want to go from one
configuration to the other one
you know if this group has cash flow and
property then that group has cash on
property t
and you want to or if and only if and
and you want to relate the two
um maybe that is you know what is this
um descriptive part
which i've never seen i mean it did i
have never seen anything like it
right i mean because you know it's very
existence right for every episode there
exists delta
so so so i i maybe this is in hidden in
these kind of you know
if you prove it you might have some
aspects of what you're asking for but it
was never considered to be relevant
but that is as you know it's a tradition
right i mean
we look at things we we are
we know because we have learned them i
mean so that this is
relevant was just never brought to our
attention period
right at least from my perspective
i mean based on um i guess just from my
own
personal opinion about sort of what's so
what's the real
technical core of of our proof you know
the recursion and things are
are kind of nice but really the the most
difficult part i think is actually the
analyzing this classical low-degree test
um in the presence of quantum provers
and um and somehow that to me that's
like the most mysterious thing i mean
even
even in the in the deterministic case
where there's no non-commuting things
going on
uh even the classical proof of the low
degree test is quite non-trivial and to
me it's very mysterious
and i do probably have better intuition
about it but
um anyways that's just my
yeah and that's something which i
learned today from your talk this was
clearer than
the talks i've seen before so
so thanks for that henry could you
clarify low degree test versus
low individual degree test and the
subtleties there
oh yeah it's um just different
definitions of when you're counting
degree of a polynomial
do you just look at the the total degree
of all the
exponents uh in a monomial or do you uh
count like the
maximum degree of any variable um and so
those differences um
so there's different flavors of low
degree tests and you get different
parameters
and we could we can analyze just one of
them this this little individual degree
test
right so so maybe we can move on to
audience questions adam actually met do
you see any
um there was a ex fairly long discussion
in the chat
about um how to go from your talk which
was about a
t-bonded um halting problem to the
complete halting problem
um so maybe if you want to say a couple
sentences about that
oh um uh right so
essentially um it's
i guess the the way that in my talk i
presented sort of like a top down
you know you start with t and then you
want to get the verifier as small as
possible
but actually the way it really works in
the mip star
protocol is the the verifier has some
fixed amount of time and it asks the
provers to continue
going upwards to to keep on
generating larger and larger proofs
until it has a proof of
uh that it holds in some finite time
and you know only the provers know how
how much time that is
but uh the result of the interaction is
that the verifier knows
that all of these proofs have been
recursively connected in the right way
down to the very bottom
that's just the high level and obviously
without knowing how long it took
right
any other questions
um no
i don't see any adam do you see anything
different
can i ask a question even though i'm a
finalist
yeah please of course so henry uh
i'm just very intrigued by this
entanglement test that you have
and i i know i've asked some variant of
this question to anal before
you know i wasn't savvy enough to
understand the answer then
maybe i'm better now um
is it the case that if i want to prove
that i have at least
if i want the provers to convince me
that they have at least eight bits of
entanglement
uh or in other words soundless condition
is if they have a bits of entanglement
then
less than a bits they should not be able
to convince the verifier
i am happy to require them to have a
huge number for every a there exists a b
such that if they have b bits of
entanglement they will definitely be
able to convince me
and i'd like to know is there
can i do this protocol with a constant
number of bits of communication
independent of a and b
um so a and b is the gap i guess yeah
for every a
i want to show there exists a b
such that distinguishing between having
at most a bits of
entanglement and at least b bits
will require constantly many bits of
communication
the constants are independent so there
exists a universal constant is that for
all either exists b
is this true is this not true
um sorry how would you show the
at most b so i don't want
most b i want at most a if they have at
most a bits then i don't want to be
convinced
if i have but to be able to convince
this protocol they might require at
least three bits
okay so i
i mean there has to be some dependence
on a and b and
i think um roughly speaking there should
be some protocol that depends on
i guess the komogorov complexity of
describing a and b or at least some get
the gap between them
then then there's some protocols
complexity and communication depend on
their description lengths i see so if i
fix the constant then you're saying
there's only some finite constant
amount of entanglement that i can uh
verify out of it
and how does this all work when
kolmogorov complexity is itself sort of
not an absolute
thing it depends on my encoding of
turing machines
right well because i guess in these
proofs you're choosing a particular way
of encoding
turing machines
okay so all right okay so uh so it's not
like there's another universal constant
out there that i've missed uh okay uh
you're saying it's going to depend on a
and p some at some level
right
great thanks um
is there time for another panelist to
panel this question
oh definitely yes because i really want
to know
maybe uh for henry and and other authors
here or just anybody
um what are the pros i think this is so
this is relevant to the question of can
we
make a proof that would be more
digestible to a broader range of
mathematicians let's say
um what are the prospects for proving um
for disproving con embedding without
something like the low degree test
is there any hint that we could just do
it entirely without it
that would be the counterpoint to saying
we should really start thinking about
efficiency questions in
approximate representation theory if we
could just take it out entirely
and maybe we don't need to do it
i mean i'm so i've been so steeped in it
that of course i don't see a way
around it i guess one one thing i can
say is um
if if we don't use the low degree test
we use something simpler um like instead
of using pcps we
use something the precursor to pcps
which is the cook levin
theorem like this is a very efficiently
uh
checkable proof but it's it's um
not very robust then we can actually use
something
uh the proof becomes much simpler and
then essentially we can reprove your
uh result uh where you you separate
the you show that computing the the
value of entangle
non-local games uh exactly is is
undecidable
um
so um
what do you think about trying to do um
because you could try and do
uh because it's also the case like the
low degree test really helps you get the
gap that you need in mipstar
between um you know uh um
between being able to uh satisfy the
to prove it when you do halt and and uh
fail when you don't
don't halt but um you also have
proven for three players that uh you
um uh
that um if you don't have a gap then
um checking whether or not you have a
uh let's say a salute well okay we don't
have the result of that but we could say
something like um
showing if we could show that uh if you
could
checking whether or not a synchronous
game can be played perfectly in our
omega
um if that is uh pi 2 complete
um that would disprove khan as well
right and it doesn't involve a gap you
don't need to know anything about a gap
there it's just a
that's true but the proof that you have
for three players that you can do this
with not for synchronous games
for three player games uses the mystery
equals re as a
black box so if you could somehow just
jump directly to proving that
maybe you could take out
right um so i guess one thing it's like
now we know that we can
that can be done with two players so
like with synchronous games
but yeah you're right it's interesting
that even to prove a gapless result we
still need a gap
in in the middle um
uh yeah i'm not sure if
how else to get around it but
um so actually but maybe
it is um worth mentioning that of course
um there were other variants of the con
embedding problem
not involving two parties but multiple
parties and you know at some point
um from an operator algebra point of
view unfortunately it wasn't clear if
you disprove it for five parties that
you automatically disprove it for two
so um that probably
i would have suspected you know that
that disproving it from more parties is
easier but it turns out that
that was not such a big difference right
i mean
simply because the complexity of the
proof for more parties is all
it's harder and then we no fewer things
to do or they know
further things to do so that that's
very interesting but i mean somehow with
the negative solution the
difference between multipliers and two
players
on that question is washed away but it's
super interesting whether in some other
context
there's a real difference between
multiplayer protocols
and two player protocols and
you know maybe there are some you know
even some applications in finding
extremely nice
multi-layer entanglement tests by by
such an inductive procedure who knows i
mean so so i think from a quantum info
perspective
this also opens a lot of additional
questions
but i'm i'm not an expert there but i
suspect
henry knows much more about you know how
to
rewrite this into a protocol which is
really convincing
another person that we have the best
quantum computer in the world
right loosely speaking
speaking yeah the three versus two
question is that still
uh for for proving uh um pi zero two
completeness is that still
uh is that still open or i
i think um yeah i mean that's something
that
um is being written up so okay
maybe i shouldn't have asked no
yeah so um
well this is this is great actually just
to just for completeness
uh henry let me um could you could you
comment on
um on the relationship of mit star equal
to re to
the quantum pcp conjecture at least the
games version of it
oh um uh
i can say something and again i'd
probably you know i think
onan i should feel free to comment
because he's worked on this for a
while um but i believe that
it depends on what you mean by the
quantum pcp conjecture so there's
there's two variants there's the games
version the local hamiltonian version
for the games version you can ask uh one
way of formulating is that it's
qma hard to decide the
the value of a non-local game or
approximate it to within some constant
um and and that strictly speaking is is
implied by
uh mi p star equals re i mean it's not
just kyo my heart but
r e hard um but but one thing that's
missing from that is in order for um
uh in order for the prover to convince
you of a q a hard language
um they they need to use they need to
essentially solve the halting problem
for
you know as far as we know um or maybe
not the halting problem but say
something that we believe to be much
harder than
than uh qma so you can ask if you had a
quantum prover who
who only has qma power like they get
some quantum witness and they just want
to prove to you that this
witness is uh say the ground state of
the local hamiltonian
can they can they prove the c with a
constant gap and that's still open
great um so
well let's um you know this was this was
really uh
fascinating it was a great talk henry
and
and a wonderful panel so thank you
everybody and
also the audience uh their questions so
um let's see uh we
um we can you know we can continue
to uh to our discussion on
gather town so i've posted the link
there
and um next week we'll have our last
quantum colloquium for this semester uh
we'll take a break for the summer after
next week and then resume in the fall so
next week it's going to be
uh it's going to be ronald devos
talking about quantum optimization so
um so thanks everybody and and
see you on gabiton